do you have an idea of how you want to
start actually having not a bad idea
what is it we can go to the train
station and film like a small dialogue
there are you joking after this we'll
record this first and then record an
intro later
okay
are you choking pack everything up and
go yeah i was like i'll just i'll just
do my regular intro maybe just just as a
safe as a safeguard yeah here's up guys
my name is
we are back at it again with the
reactions because something amazing just
dropped there's been a new demo that
someone has made using unreal engine 5 a
solo artist i'm told an independent solo
artist and apparently it's the most the
best looking most photo realistic thing
the world has ever seen right tim yep
so that's why i'm sitting on this couch
about to watch a video that tim has
prepared for me that i have not seen so
we're going to embark on a journey here
link to this will be in the description
below and
well i don't know i mean to give some
backstory i've just seen a bunch of news
articles like throughout the week being
like this is the best this is the most
like amazing looking unreal engine 5
demo the world has ever seen
and then i haven't watched it yet as
usual i never seem to watch anything so
let's take a look
damn
this looks like real life
oh my goodness
oh there's so many things going on here
maybe how long is this uh 200 minutes
i don't know if i should watch this
whole thing first and then talk about it
or if i should just pause
now this looks so good
i genuinely did not think this was even
a video game i thought it was real life
and then he's gonna cut well but like
yeah it's in not a real environment
either
it's a 3d environment damn this is this
is
i like the cutting
oh are we gonna see a train
oh
this is a dynamic lighting tech demo as
soon as you see the lights
okay
all right this took a turn
okay
running in on another five using lumen
no night okay well yeah no no no that's
the other thing this is not real time
this is not real time this is not real
time okay because that was gonna be my
next question
i was gonna ask if this was rented in
real time it's not how do you know if it
was
but was it used like why was it not real
time um just the image quality drops a
lot so this was rendered it's a high res
render around seven
frames per second okay and he can run at
real time 30 to 50 fps
at 144
p for the daytime scene of that okay
and then that's on an rtx 20. it's not
like it's like path traced or anything
it's it is kind of real well yes 7 fps
yeah so that's that's just a random
thing but
he runs it like if he plays the scene
that's 30 to 50 fps on a 40 and 40 p
like resolution okay
and then that he's running down on an
island
was this random like 4k or something uh
if he can run it at 30 to 50 fps on a
1440p then
as if it would drop that much all right
well yeah i mean where do we begin with
this uh is there anything else here i
wonder why i wasn't running in real time
i guess the lighting probably
the because there's not that much detail
going on here but everything is
extremely high resolution
and
it's probably like super sampled which
means that it's random like higher and
then scaled down so it's for example a
really good way to get rid of like the
jagged lines from aliasing yeah okay um
so i imagine that he probably at 7 fps
he probably rendered it to like an 8k or
something
buffer and then down sampled it
um
yeah okay let's let's talk about this so
first of all what makes this look
photorealistic because
there is really not much going on here
and like he's obviously done a very good
job but there are a lot of key things
that we can talk about as to why this
looks as good as it does and i think the
first thing to note is that it's filmed
in portrait mode
and he obviously has used some kind of
manual camera so he's either like taken
maybe a phone and recorded motion from
it literally walking around this world
or maybe like vr goggles or something
like that um because obviously like if
you look at the way that the animation
of the camera is it's like a person
filming or like a person literally
moving around and looking at things
so immediately if this was on a static
camera it would look worse much worse
right it would just it wouldn't look
necessarily that bad because obviously
we know movies cinematically are filmed
in a very stable sense right
but i think that's definitely like you
know the kind of portrait mode and the
shaky life-like realistic camera
animation
is what's definitely helping this
look much better so you had it on the
money with the second one it's a vr
controller
it's a vr controller used for motion
tracking oh okay a vr like controller or
a headset i think a controller used for
the motion tracking of the camera
so it's like he held it out in front of
him i think i think so i guess like like
a phone he didn't go into too much
detail but he did link a channel in the
youtube like in in the comments yeah
showing how to do okay recreate this
event
yeah the other thing to note is the way
that the colors are
so
like look how blown out those highlights
are
yeah he's kind of the expert he's
exposing for this section over here
but this is just so overexposed and
blown out yeah that's how cameras and
especially phone cameras work right if
they don't have the fancy hdr like you
know ai whatever processing that they do
these days but in general that's how
cameras work that's not how game engines
work obviously there's no
reason for this to be overexposed like
they could have brought that down and
then the whole thing would look very
unnatural but you would see all the
detail yeah but the way these highlights
blow out
and that's probably just to do with
unreal engines like post processing or
like the way their bloom kind of fits in
with like well it's really just like the
tone mapping at the end of the day and
how they map the hdr color space into
like a low dynamic range that we see
here
um but that's definitely that's
contributing so much because you can see
how re like this looks so realistic
because of it if this was like the
actual color of the sky and it was all
in like hdr and you could see it all
that would also ruin this shot and as it
pans to the actual
train station like it does
as a phone camera does it just yeah well
adaptive exposure on it yes
yeah which exactly which works very much
the same way in engines as it does in
like a literal camera right it just like
you can you can kind of get a histogram
of like the entire scene see what the
light values are and then try and
average it and smoothly dial down the
exposure yeah um to try and kind of
expose for well either a specific point
or a wide area or
you know
a region of the frame
whatever
now the interesting thing is like the
geometry so like he did mention some of
the foliage i don't know if this is the
foliages from kwikselmega scans in that
message at the end but possibly but
everything else like these rocks look
kind of detailed but apart from that if
you look at um
everything else like everything is quite
low
poly like not low poly in the sense that
it's like a low poly style but there's
not like this isn't like you know that
unreal engine 5 demo with nano
this isn't this isn't like that unreal
engine 5 demo where it it's like you
know in the desert and there's all these
there's billions of rocks or whatever
and cliff faces geometry like this is
like if you look at this you know you've
got walls you've got stairs you've got
um you know the train kind of station
and like all these flat surfaces
uh where the a lot of work has gone into
is texture right so the texturing of
these things is really
quite good except for i noticed one
thing at the end which i thought was a
bit weird
i don't know exactly where it was i
think it was here yeah look look at how
clean
these look
why are these so dirty
see like the water and the walls of
these things are so dirty but this is
like so clean
it's the time
it's concrete the dirty part is concrete
and that's yeah yeah but still that's
too clean for it that's too clean yeah
it's gonna be a bit more scratched it's
not because everything else is that's
the thing like look at all the wear and
tear everywhere
he's done a really good job with wear
and tear but i don't know i don't
that kind of when i saw that i was kind
of like yeah but again that's just
because at this point you know what are
you doing like you're just looking at
this nitpicking being like oh let me
finally let me find something to talk
about because it's just such a it's such
a great it's looking so so personal
really yeah
and to be honest like the so so here i'm
beginning to see like this doesn't look
photorealistic to me
right
maybe the way the ao is playing i see
the outlines of these rocks maybe maybe
they're a bit too cartoony or something
maybe the way that the d like lumen is
bouncing or trying to within those rocks
and whatever like if this was a ray
traced shot this would look very
different i think so like in in that
sense it's it's kind of full it kind of
falls apart i think the daylight shot
looks looked much better
than the knight so like this shot for
example i don't think it looks as good
as that shot
right okay like this to me looks more
realistic and to be honest like
daytime shots
daytime in general has a much
easier
lighting scheme right because if you if
you think about the light here
well i mean i don't know what like
there's some interior lights but the
light is mostly just coming from the sky
it's just like you've got the
directional light that you see over here
it's got motion blur as well that's
interesting um it's got uh that's
probably also why it looks kind of like
it's filmed as well because you got the
motion blur of like a camera and stuff
um but yeah like the directional lights
coming through the windows and that's
how we have our main light right whereas
over here
look at all these lights they literally
are responsible for lighting the whole
scene there might be like a moonlight or
something
but
when i think when you get into this
especially when it's quote unquote real
time
meaning that like
this isn't ray traced over like i don't
know several minutes or hours per frame
where it can actually bounce all of
these lights around and figure out
exactly what the image should look like
i think in these situations where you
are still bound by a real-time kind of
uh budget
it becomes really difficult to get a
realistic image with this many lights
when it's when literally the whole light
contribution of the image depends on
just these lights you know what i mean
if there was also a skylight then the
impact of these lights would be much
lower right
but when there's not when it's like all
these lights are lighting the entire
scene they're responsible for it all
i think at that point it yeah it's just
it's just difficult to make this look
as realistic in real time yeah i i think
that if he just switched on like unreal
engines path tracer
for this
shot right here
it'd probably look
diff quite a bit more different or at
least more different than say this
and again i'm just you know i'm just
making stuff up i have no idea
but i just i have a feeling that that's
that's what it would be like the thing
is though right
as far as photo realism go like hey
distinguishes from from like real life
i would say yes it's it's easier to
distinguish the night scene yeah yeah
but as far as like a video game
production goes i would say this is like
this makes for much more interesting
like imagine playing horror game in this
it feels close enough to photo realism
where it's like hey this could be me
walking at a train station at night
but but also it's like kind of
manageable you know the only problem i
see with that is that i think i agree
with you if it was in vr
or if the camera was
responsive
to your actual real-life movements okay
if you're playing with this with a
controller
this isn't like
available for download or anything the
scene right this is all
okay i wonder if he'll if he'll do that
because that would be cool i would i
would be interested to see like a normal
player controller on this because again
like
you know at the end of the day this is
an amazing looking demo and i don't want
to take anything away from that at all
but i'm just thinking that like if this
was in a game
if it was feasible to put this even into
into a game right because there's a lot
of detail going on here it's 7 fps right
it's
this isn't really
like the most real-time thing in the
world that you could probably actually
ship right and it's definitely more of
like a tech demo than it is or just a
piece of art really than it is an actual
game however if you could bring it back
into that space
and you had like a normal kind of player
controller with a you know you're
playing with a controller or whatever
and the camera's moving around normally
and you're sprinting around the scene
yeah i wonder how much how much
different it would look because i'm
telling you like this camera shake stuff
and just the way the camera moves and
the motion blur and everything that adds
like so much to this you know especially
at night but just looking at stills from
the daylight that's what i'm that's what
i'm getting at yeah the way the exposure
is balanced the way this motion blur
works the way
all of this stuff is laid out
apart from like you know there's no
people it feels a bit eerie because
there's just nothing going on you're
alone yeah you know what i mean
which you know i i don't know what this
person's intentions were maybe they were
to make
just maybe this is just a work of art
that happens to look better that's what
he does he goes forward yeah as much
photorealism as possible and makes
different demos different right so he
has a couple well that's what i mean
kind of like maybe like he he was like i
want to just make it look
good but i want it to be eerie and alone
and that's kind of the
message behind the artwork or whatever
versus like
you know because if this i think if
the the biggest thing that's weird about
this is almost like
there's just no people anyway you know
and so that also in a way subtracts from
the realism because how often are you in
a train station during the middle of the
day like that it's like that you know
what i get looking at this this is like
a ghost town train station because think
about it those youtubers don't have a
lot of narrative a lot of time it is the
literally the sounds that you're
listening to right now and this is by
the way this is based like the artist is
in japan and it's based on a train
station in tokyo okay cool um but yeah
this this watching this feels like this
is a ghost town and you're walking at a
train station in the ghost town yeah
because like i like watching those
videos that like abandoned like shelters
or whatever and he's just they're always
gonna die yeah yeah yeah i guess like
this is just ambient noise and sounds
and stuff like that no it's it's really
really nice i'm assuming this lighting
is dynamic
like for all of these shots i'm not sure
yeah actually yeah it is because
nothing's baked
he can play this yeah
no no no i know but like dynamic i just
mean dynamic in the sense that the
lights the light isn't moving
and that he's not he hasn't baked
anything i don't i don't
but but it but he did say it was lumen
and i i missed like lumen obviously i'm
sad that that train never came i was
looking forward to seeing the train hmm
because that's the other thing right
this is the other interesting thing
about this is this is fully static right
the only thing that isn't is when he's
moving the flashlight around that's the
only thing that gives you any sense
of movement apart from the camera
because like obviously shadows move as
well as just the camera
when you've got this right here yeah
it's just mostly again mostly like
you know things that make this photo
realistic number one camera
and camera not just animation but the
way that the exposure plays with the
camera as well and the way it's exposed
and all that stuff very
realistic
number two just the the texture detail
is fantastic maybe number two tight
texture detail and actual lighting
right because the lighting
you know lumen and all of that stuff
just the way the light's calculated is
obviously very very very good and then
yeah like the 3d models are like
whatever it's probably the last because
they're not that
well yeah even he says like um for this
project i wanted to get as close as
photorealism as possible
um
where was it ah yeah but
i didn't use nano some models are
created using the standard low poly
workflow yeah well you you don't need
nanite for this
but the cool thing about this though
it was done in a month by a single
person
who did all the texturing by scratch
from scratch in painter
i think he did substance on substance
painter i think
i think that's what i mean
which kind of like like all the models
all the reference footage yeah building
this scene you know in a month by a
single person
no that's nuts and then to get it to
this kind of level of quality
that's yeah it's a great job how long
until you do this in hazel
in a month
you've got a month
you start now
why are you still here
you should be working
wouldn't hazel do this though
um
i guess there's no reason why well
look like we we would obviously need to
have better rentering
[Laughter]
like we would need better like a a
better lighting engine okay um that'd be
the biggest part
but like there's no reason why obviously
these models and textures wouldn't work
in hazel they just wouldn't look as good
because
um
well yeah because
you know this is probably using well
lumen which uses
like ray tracing
to an extent to get better global
elimination like just indirect lighting
which we don't have indirect lighting at
all yeah right so therefore of course if
we just chucked this into hazel it would
look not very good
we might cut this part
[Laughter]
but there's no reason why we couldn't
like
eventually get something like this
working yeah because again i don't see
anything like literally impossible going
on here like
if we had all the source assets and
everything yeah we could get some i
think if i
sat down and did nothing for the next
two to three months i could probably
build all the tech for this
kind of thing and i'm not saying it
would look the same or as good but it
would be 90 of the way there okay wow
that's kind of cool not too bad i have
other stuff to do
hope you guys enjoyed this little look
at this amazing demo what did you guys
think leave a comment below i do
actually have another channel where i do
reactions kind of like this but more on
like games and all that it's called more
cherno there'll be a link to it in the
description below so if you want to see
more reactions take a look at that
channel and i will see you next time
goodbye
[Music]
you